geneviève legay militante
altermondialiste bonjour geneviève
longue et merci d'être avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france alors cette
critique adressée aux élus et notamment
aux députés n'est pas nouvelle
qu'est ce que vous reprochez exactement
aux parlementaires bonjour du point de
vue politique les lobbys les lobbys
représentent les multinationales donc
les députés en marche
les élus sont élus pour le public et le
libéralisme capitalisme donc ils sont
ils sont des gagneurs des start up
ils veulent le profit le marché réglera
tout mais on voit bien que c'est faux le
marché ne règle pas tout alors la
question il trouve utile intérêts
inavouables ont-ils quand je pense pas
je pense que ils ont peur de l'opinion
publique
s'ils avouent qu'ils sont qui sont en
lien avec les lobbys ça voudrait dire
que il te montrerai que les lobbys
interfèrent interfère sur les décisions
politiques sur les votes d'assemblée
nationale
donc on le voit bien avec le lobby
monsanto pour les pesticides les engrais
chimiques
on voit bien que de recul pour le
glyphosate par exemple geneviève le gars
qu'est ce que vous demandez vous
exactement la publication
des agents tu as des agents de la part
des parlementaires ou tout simplement le
fait que les parlementaires arrête
d'avoir des rendez vous avec ce genre de
lobbyistes moi je pense que sa part lui
et d'être que quand on apprend que ce
soit l'assemblée nationale où que ce
soit l'assemblée européenne
les lobbys sont là toute la journée a
indiqué aux députés ce qu'ils doivent
voter ou pas je trouve je sais c'est
herman que de démocratie et le fait que
qui le dites pas ça pour robin qui cache
quelque chose
alors que si qui d'une certaine façon
attaques dont vous êtes militant tout
transparancy international sont
également des lobbys des nombreuses ong
sont entendus dans les salles des
commissions du parlement qui est
autorisé et qui interdire au regard des
principes démocratiques
alors là je ne suis pas en tant que
représentant d'attac oui je suis attaque
mais là je suis en tant que citoyenne
intermedia liste moi je pense pas qu'on
peut qu'on peut comparer attaque l'autre
vous avez dit avec avec les lobbys les
lobbyings c'est une puissance financière
très importante comme jeudi représente
les multinationales alors que attaque
les associations ong qui ceux qui se
battent pour plus de transparence
ce sont des gens qui représentent la
source ce qu'on appelle la société
civile
l'opinion publique donc moi je peux pas
rentrer je peux pas entendre que vous
mettiez les lobbys au même niveau que
attaque c'est pas possible
merci beaucoup genève le guet d'avoir
été avec moi ce matin
sur rt frange rappelle que vous êtes
militante altermondialiste merci
beaucoup